bonsoir dr amant merci d'être avec nous
alors il fallait pas coutume depuis une
semaine vous le savez on comptabilise le
nombre de victimes dans les ehpad c'est
pas le cas ce soir en raison d'un
problème technique mais les chiffres
sont de mauvais augure
hier on nous les donner est ce que cette
situation dans les ehpad nous inquiètent
particulièrement la situation dans les
ehpad nous inquiète depuis depuis le
début un on avait dit nous on a supprimé
les visites à domicile des médecins
on fonctionne avec avec le médecin
coordinateur de nepad et on ne fait plus
de monde c'est plus de co2 de devises à
domicile on avait critiqué le fait que
les familles
ne puisse pas venir mais on s'aperçoit
que c'est pas suffisant que les
soignants eux sortent rencontre du monde
et est l'absence de test fait qu' il y
en a certainement qui ont contaminé des
personnes fragiles et donc ce qui devait
arriver est en train d'arriver
les les personnes âgées fragiles parce
que je rappelle quand même que quand on
voit dans une épave
c'est pour les trois dernières années de
la vie donc on est on est on a vraiment
des fois les deux des polypathologies on
est on est fragile et donc ces personnes
là par contre premier c'est ce qu'il
fallait craindre
justement vous parliez des tests docteur
olivier verront annoncé hier une
opération massive de dépistage hors des
personnels et des résidents dans les
ehpad
ça arrive trop tard tout arrive trop
tard les masques sont arrivés trop tard
le le fait que le fait qu'on ne dépiste
pas les gens qu'on n'ait pas de masque
pour mettre à la population l'exemple de
la corée du sud je le cite souvent mais
ils ont réussi à enrayer une épidémie
qui partait vraiment très très fort
parce que la population est masqué par
ce qu'ils ont fait des tests massif
parce qu'ils ont suivi les personnes qui
étaient contaminés qu'ils ont fait ici
allez allez contrôler donc
malheureusement on prend elles sont de
2,7 de cette pandémie mais messi il est
clair que on peut pas se permettre de ne
pas avoir de stock ou protéger la
population et pour protéger le personnel
soignant un docteur ramon clairement
voulu tout est arrivé trop tard on sait
aujourd'hui que le gouvernement avait
été prévenu il ya eu plusieurs rapports
y compris même par jérôme c'est le mans
qui avait bien en allemand prévenu de
cette possible épidémie
bill gates des rapports de la cia bref
on ne les compte plus pourquoi le
gouvernement n'a pas réagi
selon vous visiblement ce gouvernement
des pôles seuls en europe à ne pas avoir
réagi un lait on voit bien que les
populations banque de masques que les
soignants banque de masquer les seuls
qui ont l'air de sortir leur épingle du
jeu ce sont les allemands qui ont quatre
fois plus de lits de réanimation que les
français et qui prennent des des
patients français en réanimation
ja il y aura une morale il y aura une
des causes des conclusions à tirer de
cette de ces tristes épisodes et de
cette impréparation et j'espère qu'elles
seront vraiment tirer pour revenir juste
quelques instants sur la situation dans
les ehpad vous avez fait allusion la
critique un concernant la solitude de
ces personnes-là l'impuissance des
familles notamment pour leur venir en
aide
est ce que réellement on prend le
problème dans le bon sens vous venez de
le dire vous même ce sont des trois
dernières années de vie est ce qu'on n'a
pas plutôt intérêt justement à rendre la
vie peut-être plus agréable aux risques
voilà légèrement supérieur on peut
mourir de solitude aussi oui mais
rendent la vie plus agréable en ce
moment c'est c'est leur éviter
d'attraper d'attraper le comique 19
parce que il est clair que dans les
ehpad quand quelqu'un de très âgés de
polypathologiques fait at rappelé que 8
on est on est tout de suite dans les
soins dans les soins palliatifs on n'est
plus dans le curatif parce qu'on sait
très bien qu'on peut pas intubé et leur
mettre une assistance respiratoire
les personnes âgées polypathologiques
fragiles ne le supporte pas donc on est
immédiatement dans le palliatif donc
c'est vrai que si c'est pour quelques
semaines de confinement
on peut se débrouiller après il ya
toujours il ya toujours des tablettes
dans l'est dans les ehpad
on peut on peut communiquer avec avec
skype
même si c'est par la personne âgée qui
va faire la manipulation mais on peut
communiquer avec les tablettes avec
facetime et c'est donc tout ça c'est
possible de le faire de façon totalement
sécurisée et sans que les personnes se
sentent isolés vous savez la plupart
celles qui ont celle qui ont leur
conscience et ses clients leurs
jugements sont tout à fait capables de
comprendre pourquoi leur famille ne
vient pas les voir vous parliez
justement si ça ne devait durer qu'un
temps l'occurrence là on nous dit tous
les jours un edouard philippe
sans nous le rappeler le confinement va
durer d'ailleurs se refuse à évoquer une
stratégie de déconfinement quelle est la
réaction du médecin que vous êtes
on sait très bien que quand ils ont dix
quinze jours de confinement et qu'on a
vu là alors la horde des français qui
quitté paris pour aller se réfugier en
province ils avaient tous compris que ça
n'allait pas durer 15 jours tout ce qui
pourrait partir et qui avait du
télétravail sont partis avec armes et
bagages et enfants et ils savaient très
bien que ça va durer ça allait durer
plus qu'un jour est là en ce moment
parler des confinement est totalement
prématuré 534 morts par jour 800 hier on
voit bien que ça
ça ne baisse pas et je pense qu'on fera
sans doute le bilan à la mi mai mais à
la mi mai on sera certainement pas tirés
d'affaires il suffit de regarder les
italiens qui en quinze jours d'avancé
sur nous ils sont loin d'être tiré
d'affaires et on parle pas de
déconfinement on voit quelques
opérations de communication en chine
disant qu' il des confine des quelques
quartiers de pékin mais qu'ils envoient
sur la grande muraille mais si vous avez
vu les images fournies par les chinois
sur la grande muraille à un chinois tous
là cinquante mètres donc donc c'est de
l'opération communication pure jean paul
hamon vous dites oui quand on voit cette
horde et des français voilà
volontairement provocatrice mais enfin
il n'y a pas un petit peu de
culpabilisation de deux de ces français
tout serait de la faute de ceux qui
veulent quitter paris il n'empêche c'est
quand même compliqué ce confinement dans
une ville comme paris dans des
appartements où on est avec des enfants
est-ce que ce n'était pas peut-être au
gouvernement d'anticiper un petit peu
plus peut-être cette situation de nous
fournir des tests des masques vous
l'avez dit vous-même la corée s'en sort
mieux les allemands aussi
le gouvernement vous savez il a fait il
a fait ce qu'ils pouvaient un bon ils
ont constaté
ils ont constaté qu' il pouvait pas
avoir de masques que deux le stock de
masques avait disparu où il n'avait pas
été renouvelé il avait quand même deux
mois pour leur faire et relancer la
machine à fabrication française puisque
en chine visiblement on se fait piquer
les les contenus des avions sur les
tarmacs parce qu'ils sont plus offrant
donc tout ça
on est ronde et à la merci le on est à
la merci le président a rappelé enfin qu
il fallait qu on ait une indépendance de
production pour les matériels de
protection
il a pas parlé de l'indépendance de
production de test et pourtant c'est ce
qu'il faudrait avoir maintenant pour le
déconfinement c'est vrai que les
parisiens qui ont eu la chance d'avoir
des parents qui pouvaient travailler en
télétravail et quelques une maison à la
campagne au bord de la mer bon bah
c'était plutôt une bonne chose de partir
même si même si en faisant ça ils
prenaient le risque de faire flamber
l'épidémie semble quand même que c'est
pas été le cas et que une fois sur place
ils ont été raisonnables ou les a
contraints à être raisonnable donc il
faut rester il faut rester confiné
maintenant il ya il ya que cette il ya
que cette façon de contenir l'épidémie
de faire en sorte que comme dans tous
les autres pays il faut éviter que les
services de réanimation soient débordés
parce que qu'on ne se retrouve pas dans
la situation italienne où ils ont été
obligés de choisir entre ce qu'ils
allaient réanimer ce qu'ils n'avaient
pas réanimer
pour le moment en france ça tient mais
ça tient à un fil et je pense qu'il est
prématuré de parler des compliments
justement la situation est la solution
ne semble venir vous venez de le dire
d'ailleurs que du confinement strict des
français quid d'un éventuel traitement
est ce que vous vous savez de l'espoir
ont ces différents traitements nous
sommes en train de
de tester un peu partout en france il ya
des études qui sont en cours il ya des
études qui sont en cours il ya cette
fameuse chloroquine associé à
l'azithromycine qui j'espère que l'étude
qui est en cours avec l'université
d'angers
bah pas montré l'utilité de ce
médicament tout le monde le souhaite
mais pour le moment on en a aucune
preuve donc ce serait ce serait bien que
une étude indépendante
une pré étude scientifique nous nous
fasse la preuve que ce médicament est
utile et on attend ça avec impatience
nous aussi effectivement merci et
jean-paul à mon médecin généraliste
président de la fédération des médecins
de france merci beaucoup d'avoir été en
direct avec nous sur rt france